da dessen die eier sally die russen
vor jungs sorry aber ich schlag dich zum
ritter
dich zum oberliga und dichter den film
anschaut wie die preise zu hoch
sorry aber ich muss in die küche sind
verpacken jung ganz tolle veranstaltung
ist vorbei
es gibt eine abmahnung
also dann nimm du die kids und ich
praktisch brachen ein
du hast jungs auf die neuer sind
heute praktisch also eine torte zur
serie game of thrones thema für uns ist
die weltweit erfolgreichste serie und
jetzt startet gerade die siebte staffel
nur auf sky entertainment in der serie
geht es um macht um den thron kampf um
liebe um intrigen auch um hass man
sollte vielleicht dazu sagen dass die
serie erst ab 16 ist das heißt kinder
sollten die serie auf keinen fall sehen
das ist wirklich nur was für erwachsene
und deswegen habe ich auch lange
überlegt ob ich überhaupt eine torte auf
meinem kanal machen soll
wobei wirklich ganz ganz viele zuschauer
mich danach gefragt haben
auch der borat und die jungs sind
wirklich totale game of thrones fans und
sitzen jede woche da und warten jetzt
einfach nur noch auf den serienstart der
siebten staffel am 17 07 startet also
die serie game of thrones auf sky morath
und die jungs sie freuen sich schon
richtig drauf und momentan gibt es das
sky ticket entertainment das kostet im
juli und august nur einen euro und ihr
könnt euch dort sogar die staffeln eins
bis sechs komplett anschauen
in originalsprache oder auch auf deutsch
und das ganze ist monatlich kündbar und
ich wünsche euch empfehlen dass vor der
ersten staffel ohne hinzuschauen das
heißt wir sind um nächsten drei monate
beschäftigen was in zwei monaten hat man
das durch und dann startet eben im juli
jetzt die siebte staffel und ihr könnt
euch dann jede woche eine neue folge
anschauen bis hin zum finale also haben
wirklich ganz ganz ganz viele zuschauer
geschrieben ob ich denn nicht eine torte
machen könnte
dann habe ich gedacht okay was überlege
ich mir also habe ich diese torte
gebacken und zwar habe ich hier eins der
drei drachen eier gebacken und im
inneren der torte habe ich eine
schokotorte red velvet mit einer herren
schokoladen ganache und einer peter
karrasch und das ganze ist wirklich
super lecker und die torte habe ich
insgesamt an drei tagen zubereitet dh
nehmt euch am besten ein bisschen zeit
und so könnt ihr dann das ganze wirklich
super toll vorbereitet jetzt spare ich
euch gar nicht länger auf die folter
sondern zeige euch wie man diese torte
herstellt angefangen bei takkt 1
los gehts jetzt mit dem drachen altes
werde ich jetzt zuerst formen und ihr
könnt das drachenei entweder aus
kuchenteig machen oder aus einer reis
christiane reiss christi masse die
besteht aus marshmallows und reis
christie's also puffreis und das ist
natürlich von vorteil denn dann ist die
masse nicht so schwer
und vor allem kann man sie beliebig
formen und muss jetzt keinen kuchen
zurechtschneiden
das heißt entscheidet ihr einfach ob die
kuchenteig macht oder weiß christ für
die restrate masse brauche ich 400 gramm
rettungsdienstes sind jetzt schoko chris
bis 400 gramm marshmallows und 30 gramm
butter
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die
marshmallows die kommen jetzt in der
pfanne dann nehme ich jetzt eine teflon
beschichtete pfanne einfach damit sie
mich an kleben und wenn die panne jetzt
auf mittlerer stufe stellen und die
marshmallows darin schmelzen
nach etwa fünf minuten sie dem massiv so
aus jetzt kommt die butter mit dazu und
dann ruhig noch mal kurz bis die butter
auch geschmolzen ist und anschließend
kommt diese klebrige masse direkt mit
sunrise christie's
[Musik]
die pfanne gibt jetzt übrigens am besten
etwas wasser rein lasst das aufkochen
und dann bekommt ihr auch alle reste
wunderbar aus und die masse hier diese
zwei heißt auch wenn sie nicht zu heiß
aussieht deswegen wird's jetzt zuerst
einmal so weit es geht mit einem
kochlöffel durch oder mit tai chi und
anschließend sehe ich mir
einweghandschuhen und dann kann ich sie
nochmals durchkneten
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die masse durchgemischt
und sich ein ziemlich klebrige
angelegenheit das heißt ihr könnt auch
die handschuhe händler noch mit sind mit
kokosfett oder zum beispiel mit butter
ein bisschen einschmieren einfach da
jetzt nicht zusätzlich jetzt werde ich
hier raus ein ei formen dh die masse
schön zusammendrücken
so wird einfach ein bisschen kompakter
und was ich ganz toll an der marshmallow
was befinden und ein weißbier geschmeckt
hat wirklich super lecker details später
wird dann auch gekauft und das ist
wirklich sehr sehr lecker
jetzt könnt ihr das uns noch mieser
kompakter song einfach so ein bisschen
auf die arbeitsfläche auch darauf
knallen und für den iphone bringen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die eiform das darf
jetzt nicht zu spitz sein sondern sollte
ein bisschen bauch liga bleiben so ist
es wirklich super und jetzt welches in
frischhaltefolie einpacken denn beim
trocknen kann es jetzt einfach passieren
dass es noch mal so ein bisschen
auseinander geht und ich möchte dass es
jetzt so in form bleibt wie ich zurecht
gedrückt haben
und dann kann ich so diese marshmallow
küsten und auf dem eis christi masse
einfach so etwa über nacht trocknen
lassen und weiter geht's mit der deko
als nächstes sind wird die schwerter
dran und die form ich jetzt aus modelle
schokolade denn modelle schokolade kann
man wirklich super toll formel man kann
daraus figuren machen oder so wie hier
auf der packung himbeeren auch machen
und die ist super einfach zu verarbeiten
weil sie durch die hand wärme weich wird
und weil sie dann einfach beim erkalten
auch wieder hart wird und die werde ich
jetzt neben ich habe jetzt ein rot ihr
könnt jede andere farbe nehmen
hauptsache etwas dunkles dem später
werden die schwerter sowieso mit pulver
farbe eingeschmiert und dann sieht man
den untergrund nicht mehr schwarz wäre
es auch möglich aber nicht mit schrot
und das habe ich jetzt bereits weiß
geknetet und rollt es jetzt mit hilfe
von becker stärke auf drei millimetern
stärke aus und da habe ich jetzt einfach
diese zwei helfer die abstand hölzer und
damit geht es echt super einfach
unter lagerte nehme ich jetzt einfach
meine socken rettung
und jetzt werde ich später zurecht
schneiden das heißt zuerst einmal die
klingen und die mache ich jetzt etwa 5
mm breit dass sich traurig oder 5 mm
breite streifen
jetzt werden gleich die klingen
zurechtgeschnitten wegen der länge muss
ich jetzt einfach mal schauen wie hoch
die torte sein wird und ich habe jetzt
hier einen extra hohen tortenring
genommen einen bug ring und zwar hatte
die höhe von 12 cm
so hoch soll in etwa später die torte
werden ich werde wahrscheinlich nur nach
neun bis zehn zentimeter hoch machen
das ist aber jetzt die ideale grundlage
damit ich hier einfach später die
schwerter front vorhin machen kann
das heißt ständig kurz zur seite und die
längsten später die werden auch ein
bisschen darüber hinaus tragen das heißt
zwölf bis 13 cm die kürzeren vorne er 8
bis 9
und deswegen schneide ich die jetzt hier
einfach zu recht eben in der länge von 8
bis insgesamt 13 zentimeter also einfach
ganz unterschiedlich
[Musik]
und damit auch eine schwemme wird muskau
an einer spitze dran
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr nochmal die zweithöchste
zu hilfe nehmen denn jetzt wirklich auch
gerade liegt und jetzt kommt in die
mitte einfach nur so ein kleiner schlitz
den können wir entweder mit einem
stumpfen messer machen oder einfach mit
dem anderen gerade gegenstand mit lineal
zum beispiel geht da auf jeden fall auch
[Musik]
noch steht das alles aus wie ein
gartenzaun aber das werden gleich
schwert klingen und die überschüssige
becker stärke die könnt ihr super
einfach mit einem pinsel einfach weg und
die klingen lassen jetzt erst mal eine
halbe stunde bis stunde an trocknen
bevor ich dann das komplette gerüst
machen
[Musik]
und deswegen sind jetzt eingetroffen und
jetzt kann ich das gerüst machen ich
habe ich jetzt einen streifen backpapier
und zwar wenn das jetzt meine torte mit
20 cm
das halte ich jetzt hier dran und da
geht so nicht ganz halb rum sondern nur
etwa ein drittel ein bisschen mehr als
ein drittel und ist auch ein leicht
höher als der tortenring das heißt es
sind jetzt schon mal so 13 zentimeter so
hoch wird es jetzt nicht aber den
brauche ich jetzt als basis und
bestreicht jetzt einfach mit etwas
kokosfett können dann mit den fingern
machen oder einfach mit einem pinsel und
des kokons wird sorgt jetzt dafür dass
ich das was ich jetzt hier darauf lege
dass es eben nicht verrutscht und jetzt
nehme ich dich schwert klingen und
fangen jetzt von hinten an das werden
jetzt mehrere schichten so etwa 3 und
das soll es so aussehen als würden die
hinteren draufstehen das heißt man muss
jetzt einmal kurz die bäcker stärke
wächst damit es besser klebt und dann
lege ich das erste in die mitte vor
anderen lege ich jetzt so hin wie einen
fächer und jetzt kommen die übrigen
schädlingen einfach rein
bis auf etwa sechs bis acht stück die
werte nämlich übrig lassen die werden
nämlich dann mit der schädlinge nach
unten hin gelegt und es ist einfach dann
die vorderste reihe und die bekommt
natürlich dann auch noch griffe und
damit die schön zusammen geben nehme ich
hier jetzt gleich essbaren kleber und
damit gebe ich dir gleich anders sobald
ich natürlich erst weiß wie sie hier
drankommen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich jetzt kann man so ein
bisschen erkennen was werden soll
ich habe jetzt hier unten die fläche
gerade abgeschnitten und ich habe ich
jetzt noch ein paar stützen drin dass
wir selbst stützen die habe ich jetzt
nur drunter gelegt damit die schweizer
einfach nicht nach unten abknicken
sondern wirklich 3d oben bleiben und
dann habe ich noch unten dran ein paar
stützen die habe ich angeklebt und so
habe ich dafür einfach so stück fresse
hier genommen und stunde geht so dass
man es eben nicht sieht für den griff
nämlich jetzt ein ganz kleines stück
modelle schokolade und formen zu einer
langen rolle
und jetzt drücke ich sind form das heißt
mit beiden händen so wie es am
kleiderbügel hinten schneide ich jetzt
was weg dieses ende nehme ich jetzt
phorms zu einer kugel und dann formt ihr
das ende hier hinten so ein bisschen
flach entweder mit einem löffel oder im
modell werkzeug da kommt etwas lieber
drauf und mit einem kleinen ball tool
kann ich jetzt die kugel auf spießen und
dann einfach hier hinten draufkleben und
so las ich den griff wird sie hinten
erstmal antrocknen und am ende sieht das
dann so aus
[Musik]
die schwerter sind jetzt angeordnet
jetzt muss ich sie trocknen lassen und
dafür stößt hier über den weg bringen
damit der parkring nicht verrutscht habe
ich den jetzt einfach hier in den
eckigen back rahmen gestellt und
streiche jetzt hier ein bisschen vom
vertraut damit das backpapier schön
daran klebt und jetzt lege ich das ganz
vorsichtig drauf jetzt fragt ihr
vielleicht warum ich das zu machen
ich möchte jetzt schon mal diese
rundliche form haben und so kann das
ganze jetzt wirklich auch vier fünf tage
durch trocknen
zwei tage wird es mindestens trocknen
lassen ich habe jetzt alles vorbereitet
und die deko teile dürfen jetzt durch
trocknen und aushärten weil mir geht's
jetzt morgen weiter aber ihr könnt im
prinzip wenn ihr auch schon eine woche
vorher zeit habt wirklich alles was ich
heute an diesem tag gemacht habe schon
vorbereiten und dann erst fünf sechs
tage später tag 2 und tag 3 machen und
somit die kuchen backen und die torte
fertig dekoriert
heute bin ich jetzt bereit für den teig
und zwar habe ich mir gedacht mache ich
eine wette velvet cake also einen roten
samt kuchen wer mein backbuch hat also
das was da hinten steht cds classic der
kennt das rezept bereits denn dieses
prozent werde ich nehme das ist ein
rührteig und ich finde die farbe rot
passt auch wirklich sec und zur torte
und ich bereite jetzt heute im takt vor
damit ich morgen die torte füllen und
fertig dekorieren kann ich zeig euch
jetzt mal die zutaten für den red velvet
traurig 350 g weiche butter 350 gramm
zucker eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt sechs zimmer war mayer 350 gramm
mehl 80 gramm kakaopulver ein viertel
teelöffel backpulver einem viertel
teelöffel natron einen esslöffel essig
500 gramm zimmer warme butter milch und
hier habe ich noch lebensmittel verpasst
in rot wichtig ist dass alle zutaten die
gleiche temperatur und am besten
zimmertemperatur haben
jetzt kommt die butter in eine große
schüssel wie könnte es jetzt mit dem
handrührgerät auch machen oder mit der
küchenmaschine das einfach sehr lange
gerührt werden
da kommt jetzt wird so kommt rein
alt und man den extrakt und jetzt lasse
ich die masse etwa vier bis fünf minuten
rühren
mit dem backvorgang ist jetzt das
schlimmste passiert was passieren kann
wenn man einer backofen ist ausgefallen
er heißt einfach nicht und deswegen habe
ich es gedacht okay ich muss jetzt kurz
stoppen denn die teilmenge es dafür zwei
backbleche gedacht das heißt ich kann
jetzt antrag nicht rühren hier rein
füllen einen backen und dann den anderen
danach denn das backpulver darin das
wirkt ja und ansonsten geht der teig
einfach nicht mehr schön auf das heißt
ich lasse ziel kurz die zutaten stehen
murat ist nämlich gerade schon los
gezogen er holt jetzt einen neuen
backofen
denn wir hatten sowieso eine neue platte
bestellt weil morath sicher hier drauf
gelegt hatte und hier leider einen riss
drin ist und die hat einfach nicht mehr
richtig funktioniert das heißt ich warte
jetzt kurz wie der backvorgang hier wird
die herdplatte unter backofen retten
ausgetauscht und dann geht es gleich
weiter mitteilte
[Musik]
da die küche jetzt gerade noch besetzt
ist setze ich mich jetzt ins esszimmer
und leitet dort das skateboard
überziehen zum präsentieren habe ich
jetzt eine kickboard platte genommen
mit 30 cm durchmesser und einem
zentimeter breite dafür nehme ich jetzt
einfach von dort reste da brauche ich
etwa drei bis 400 gramm
ich habe jetzt schon gewundert und
schwarzen von dort gemischt und das
ganze auch so ein bisschen marmoriert
ausgerollt zum kleben auf die platte
nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen essbaren
kleber und verteilt ihn mit meinem
pinsel und dann wird nur noch die von
der decke drüber gelegt und mit alufolie
ein bisschen strukturieren jetzt muss
ich nur noch die überschüsse wegnehmen
und den rand den über klebe ich jetzt
mit schwarzem klebeband und so kann das
skateboard jetzt einfach durch trocknen
bis der torte draufgesetzt wird
erst jetzt die weiche butter mit zucker
salz und vanille extrakt in etwa vier
bis fünf minuten zu einer weiß cremigen
masse verrührt jetzt für rühre ich mail
cacau backpulver und natron und die
zutaten werden dann auch gelebt jetzt
höre ich nacheinander die sechs eier ein
das heißt immer einen nach dem anderen
und jedes ei wird ungefähr 30 sekunden
ein gerührt als nächstes kommt jetzt
noch die rote lebensmittelfarbe passte
mit rein und da geht jetzt also nur
soviel dazu dass eben ein schönes roth
entsteht jetzt ruhig denn essig die
buttermilch und dem mädel mischung
einfach abwechselnd in den tag hinein
und ruhe ist aber nur noch so lange wie
nötig ich habe jetzt wieder zwei
funktionierende öffnen das heißt ich
habe jetzt die menge und wachse auf zwei
backbleche verteilt falls ihr nur einen
backofen habt ist es besser wenn ihr die
hälfte des tages zubereitet erst einmal
ein blech backt und dann die nächste
halbe menge zubereitet und das zweite
blech bagso schöner tag einfach nicht
unnötig herum und es wird alles richtig
gut jetzt portion ich das ganze das
heißt der teig wird auch vier schälchen
also auf 4 bak dringen jetzt aufgeteilt
[Musik]
wenn jetzt verteile ich den teig und
ziehen am rand so ein bisschen hoch so
packte nämlich etwas gleichmäßiger durch
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der teig in den
vorgeheizten backofen
oh ja da ist schon vorgeheizt ich habe
nämlich schnell aufreizend gemacht also
gleich mal eine funktion ausprobiert
machen was ich noch dazu sagen möchte
ich werde die bank den backofen jetzt
ausprobieren und dann nämlich auf jeden
fall in meiner küche mit also wäre
schwachsinnig wird denn hier lassen denn
ich habe also in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 30 minuten
ach gott geprägten akp krieg jetzt kann
ich auch mit dem weitermachen das heißt
hier habe ich jetzt schon das fest
und ich habe etwas modellierte rouladen
schmeckt extrem gut und damit schaffe
ich jetzt eine basis und werde das auch
schön platt machen und das ganze mit
echt schön mit den fingern weich und ich
kann das einfach ohne kleber hier daran
festmachen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die grundlage geschaffen
jetzt erkennt man auch die iphone
richtig gut und jetzt werde ich diese
nochmal antrocknen lassen das heißt
morgen stelle ich das album fertig also
am dritten tag
und ja im prinzip habe ich jetzt heute
erst mal feiern
jetzt kann ich die torte befüllen ich
habe jetzt die kuchen böden über nacht
im kühlschrank stehen und habe sie
vorher ein sind in frischhaltefolie
eingepackt zum befüllen habe ich jetzt
hier eine zahl peter karrasch
hergestellt die passt geschmacklich sehr
gut dazu
ihr könnt aber auch wenn ihr möchte zum
beispiel eine französische oder auch
eine italienische buttercreme machen die
passenden auch sehr gut
ich habe ich jetzt einen cache board mit
20 metern durchmesser und das bestreite
ich jetzt mit der garage und das hilft
daran dass die torte eben hier darauf
kleben bleibt
da kommt jetzt der erste boden drauf und
dadurch dass ich dieser dünnen gebacken
habe muss ich sie jetzt auch nicht
durchschneiden
jetzt werde ich die böden noch trinken
so bekommt man getroffen würden noch ein
bisschen saftiger und ich habe jetzt
hier einfach kaffee in so eine flasche
rein gemacht und vorne hat ihr ganz
viele kleine löcher und somit kann ich
jetzt die böden gleichmäßig trinken es
geht aber auch mit dem pinsel
jetzt streicht sich einfach immer ein
bisschen ganache zwischen die kuchen
böden und stapel die torte und werde
etwa zwei vielleicht auch drei kuchen
boden aufheben für die etwas kleinere
torte
und die ghana steht jetzt ein bisschen
flüssiger weil es einfach hier ziemlich
warm es im raum
deswegen habe ich unten so ein akku pack
drauf aber zum befüllen ist diese
konsistenz wirklich sehr perfekt
[Musik]
für die kleineren orte habe ich eine 15
cm platte und die lege ich jetzt hier
drauf das heißt ich muss jetzt hier ein
bisschen was zu schneiden zu hilfe nehme
ich jetzt einfach einen tortenring dort
auch bisschen weniger als 15
das heißt ich kann hier wirklich
ausstechen sonst muss ich den antrag
ausfüllen mit gerade deswegen werde ich
jetzt hier einfach mit messer drumherum
schneiden
jetzt sind die torten gefüllt und
dadurch dass ich die böden im
kühlschrank hatte zieht auch die ghanaer
schnell an und wird fest und jetzt kann
ich die toppen einfach mit der
restlichen ganache einstreichen und
glatt streichen und zuerst mache ich
jetzt eine erste schicht dass die krümel
binden das schicht und danach kommt die
platte schicht
[Musik]
seit wochen stehen zum kühlschrank und
jetzt werde ich mich wieder um das
drachen ein kümmern
dieses bekommt jetzt nämlich schuppen
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier nochmal
modelle schokolade in rot und schwarz
und jetzt habe ich bereits schon ein
bisschen schwarz weiß geknetet ich
machte einen farbverlauf rein das heißt
oben beginne ich mit schwarz beim mit
schwarz-rot weiter und ein bisschen
heller rot und später wird sowieso alles
mit pulver farbe und so weiter noch ein
bisschen schockiert mattiert und noch
glänzend gemacht jetzt kann ich erst
einmal kleine stücke nehmen und die
vielen ausrollen
[Musik]
und die schuppen die steche ich dann aus
mit hilfe von zwei blätter aus fächern
einmal bisschen größer einmal ein
bisschen kleiner
und dann werde ich die einfach so dran
kleben und falls es nicht ganz geben
sollte weil die oberfläche hier jetzt
schon trocken ist nehme ich einfach ein
bisschen s-bahn kleber
[Musik]
vielleicht ist da oben die schuppen sind
ins werde ich damit mache ich später
weiter ich habe ich jetzt eine von der
decke und zwar habe ich zwei mal weiß
und zwei mal verwarnen von dann
zusammengemischt und auch so ein
bisschen marmoriert gelassen und jetzt
hinausgewählt jetzt kann ich die große
torte damit eindecken
das heißt ich begrüße jetzt mit etwas
back trend spray so wird sie
angefeuchtet und der fondant gut und
dann lege ich jetzt hier die decke
drüber
[Musik]
damit die torte hier eine schöne kannte
bekommt werde ich jetzt einfach umdrehen
und dann kopfüber glatt streichen
[Musik]
die torte gefällt mir sollte schon
richtig gut die kommt in den kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich noch die ganz kleine
torte überziehen und die werde ich so
machen dass es aussieht wie ein kleines
tuch das heißt ich nehme jetzt einfach
hier die reste schauen ob ich im
küchenschrank noch ebenso von interesse
habt ihr etwas dunkler sind kann das
ganze marmorieren so das ist einfach
aussieht wie ein schmutziges tuch und ja
und die geht so lange interessant
das tuch liegt jetzt herum und jetzt
habe ich hier drei farben ein dunkles
auto würde ich sagen orangen gespart und
die farben sind pulver farben
lebensmittel verfahren und die werde ich
jetzt einfach mit einem trockenen pinsel
auftragen so dass es einfach ein
bisschen ungleichmäßig ein bisschen
schockiert wird und einfach ein bisschen
schmutzig aussehen
[Musik]
um diese tiefen effekte zu bekommen
nämlich immer eine dunkle farbe und geht
damit dann ganz tief in diese falten
hinein
[Musik]
jetzt ist die untere dran da mache ich
jetzt eine andere technik und für alle
nass technik
die habe ich jetzt einfach mal so
genannt ich habe jetzt einfach gebilligt
das mache ich jetzt doch das
funktioniert ich nehme es ein bisschen
baktrien spray und sprüht die torte ein
jetzt einen weiteren pinsel und die wird
ja sowieso ein bisschen schmutzig
gemacht
[Musik]
hier habe ich jetzt auf meinem teller
ein bisschen schwarz und dieses orange
gemischt und hier habe ich gold und
schwarz gelöscht das gehe ich einfach
mit dem pinsel ganz leicht rein und
streifen auf die torte
[Musik]
und jetzt zum abschluss noch ein
bisschen gold schwarz
[Musik]
jetzt ist das ei an der reihe und ihr
könnt es im prinzip so lassen so ist es
auch schon schön aber auch dass
drachenei wird etwas hübscher wenn wir
ein bisschen pulver farbe nehmen darf er
nämlich jetzt ein bisschen rot schwarz
porto und später noch ein bisschen gold
und das ganze könnte jetzt entweder
wieder trockene pudern oder wieder
vorher mit back transfer einsprühen oder
aber auch die pulver farben einfach mit
bisschen alkohol oder wasser vermischen
und dann drauf machen
[Musik]
ihr seid noch den game of thrones
schriftzug machen und dafür habe ich
jetzt bilden passte ganz dünn ausgerollt
und bisschen antrocknen lassen da
schneide ich mir seine band zurecht und
dafür eignet sich das bisschen geld
hervorragend dann ist es schön
gleichmäßig
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich einen lebensmittel
farbstift die dünne seite und kann jetzt
einen schriftzug drauf schreiben und
dann kürzlich es einfach so entsprechend
der länge
[Musik]
ich bin ich fast fertig jetzt fehlen nur
noch die schwerter die werde ich jetzt
mit metallic farben malen und dann nehme
ich lebensmittel pulver farbe im gold
und silber und bisschen bronze und wenn
es dann noch besprühen
[Musik]
so jetzt kann ich die torte
zusammensetzen
wenn ihr noch ein bisschen garage gehabt
falls ihr noch nicht fertig gemacht
dann nehmt ihr die jetzt und streicht
sich hier auf die top werte und die
platte habe ich übrigens auch mit den
metallic farben noch mal ein bisschen
veredelte trocknen lassen aber echt so
eine schöne oberfläche sondern richtig
tolle lackoberfläche und die torte
platzierte jetzt nicht ganz mittig
sondern ein bisschen weiter hinten
wenn ich aber noch den schriftzug der
vorne dran muss und noch die schwerter
und deswegen ist es hier ganz gut
und jetzt sich handschuhe an damit ich
jetzt die torte anfassen kann ohne die
zu zerstören und auch das eigene wenn
ich das anfassen bringen da finger
passen drauf weil man ja auch schweiß
aus den händen hat und von daher ist
sich so besser
jetzt kommt die kleine torte drauf und
diese ziemlich schwer und auch das eis
erschwerten muss ich die untere torte
stabilisieren das mache ich jetzt mit
cake pops ticks die kommen jetzt hier
rein und dann kann ich dir jetzt hier
kürzen
hier kommen jetzt auch eine kleine
schicht einer strafe so kann ich nämlich
die torte ankleben und die stäbe werden
später einfach beim anschneiden der
torte vorher entfernt und dann hat man
auch gar kein problem damit beim toto
ist
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier noch die schwerter
angeklebt und die musste ich ganz ganz
vorsichtig auf die hand drauf nehmen und
dann mit dem kleber angegeben sind ein
paar stellen da ist jetzt gold ein
bisschen weg aber das ist gar nicht
schlimm
die werde ich jetzt einfach noch eine
sind nachbearbeiten
[Musik]
jetzt verfestige ich hier noch den
schriftzug der ist noch nicht komplett
durchgetrocknet und damit aussieht wieso
eine fahne schneide ich hier noch ein
dreieck ein und tipps nur punktuell an
so dass es schön in falten legt
[Musik]
jetzt kommen auch das ei an die reihe
und damit es hier schön drauf sitzen
bleibt kommt hier zu einem
schaschlikspieß rein und dann kann das
eigen aufgespießt werden
und murat sauer die torte anschneiden
keine politik warum weil der sehr ich
morgen deswegen zwar drauf wir machen
vielleicht ist ihr den live ins nächste
bleibt das ist eine gute lehrerin und
jungs morgen machen
ok also köpfen wir dieses drachen er
jetzt nicht nur um ok dann lassen wir es
und werden die torte erst zum
serienstart am 17
essen genau das ist nämlich morgen ja
was gibt's auch zu sagen ich fand es
dass jetzt wieder richtig cool die torte
machen zu dürfen
vor allem fand ich die anfrage von sky
richtig toll mir macht es auch wirklich
super viel spaß mir torten auszudenken
für die filmbranche
für uns ist man immer was ganz
besonderes weil wir uns wirklich ganz
ganz viel zeit aufnehmen können für die
einzelnen torten und für die videos und
ich hoffe natürlich dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat falls ihr auch lust
auf die serie bekommen habt dann könnt
ihr auch skype nachschauen
das sky ticket entertainment gibt es für
im juli und august für jeweils einen
euro wie gesagt monatlich kündbar und
ich werde auf jeden fall ist auch in die
serienfertigung soll ein anschauen also
keine freunde an schon um mich würde ich
mir manchmal dass ich ertrage ja auch
nicht euch in den ritterkostüm ja ich
muss die ganze zeit lachen
also falls ihr das rezept gerne trotzdem
nochmal nachlesen wollt geht auch cds -
blog.de da stets noch mal ganz genau und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und ganz viel spaß beim
serienstart und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal bis dann so ich würde die
prinzessin sind für nein
doch nein ich werde es sicher schützen
nein ja live acts kommen
der user muss weg bleiben und die jungs
schauen sich jetzt morgen die ferien
bekommen jetzt der ganze leben schon
wieder her
warum ich in unserem 100 meter
[Musik]
murat und die jungs sie freuen sich
schon richtig drauf und momentan gibt es
das ticket entertainment für nur einen
euro das heißt im juli und im august
könnt ihr die staffel eins bis sechs
komplett für insgesamt wird zwei euro
anschauen
das ganze in sneakers okay das ganze ist
monatlich kündbar und siegers ich kann
sagen systems zwei große game of thrones
fans steht ihr sie schon bereit für die
neue staffel diesen alle geholfen
ok und ihr kennt euch die staffel
entweder auf deutsch oder sogar in der
originalsprache anschauen